let's talk about the current
opportunities and challenges that you'll
face as you enter the labor market my
first question is are these the best of
times or the worst of times to be
looking for a job and starting your
career well let's take a look at some of
the labor market realities that you face
you all recall what we referred to as
the Great Recession of 2007 and 2009
this chart shows just how many jobs we
lost during that time period well the
good news is that in fact 2015 finally
was a great year for job growth in the
u.s. we made a big dent in closing the
jobs deficit by creating nearly two and
a half million jobs so now we only need
another three million more to close the
full job deficit let's hope we keep
making progress like we did last year no
guarantees given the shaky world economy
we're in so we have to keep pressing
government and business leaders to keep
the job growth going strong
that's challenge number one but that's
only the beginning of the challenge
recall what the Occupy movement said
that 1 percent of the top earners are
getting all of the income well they were
right over 50% of income growth in the
last decade has come to the top one
percent and we have to go way back here
to 1928
to have a situation where we get that
much unequal distribution of income so
we do have an income problem but it
wasn't always this way from the end of
World War 2 down here about 1947 1948
all the way through til about 1980 we
saw an economy where wages and
productivity and profits move together
later on we're going to talk about this
as the era of the post-world War two
social contract but something happened
here note after 1980s productivity
continued to grow by over 80 percent but
wages and compensation flatlined
the average worker in the United States
economy
has only seen about a nine percent wage
increase since 1980 and in fact if you
don't have a college degree your wages
have gone down relative to the cost of
living during this time period so while
in the early stage we had what President
Kennedy said a rising tide lifts all
boats everybody worked hard and shared
in the games we have seen something
happen since 1980 that has changed that
let's now focus a little bit more
carefully on just what happens if you
are entering the labor market after
finishing high school or college at this
point in time many of you will start off
as unpaid interns or in part-time jobs
or in jobs that don't use the full
education that you've worked so hard to
achieve you'll be what we call
underemployed and it's not surprising
that given that many of your cohort are
experiencing very low levels of job
satisfaction in fact the lowest levels
that we have seen in many years back in
the 1980s this red line shows that
people under the age of 25 were like
others more than 50 percent were
satisfied with their wages their hours
of work and their opportunities to learn
on the job but now these numbers have
declined to a little over 35% and so
only about 1/3 of young people are
satisfied with their jobs how does this
really affect you well the economic
evidence is very clear if you start off
as many of you are experiencing now in
low-income jobs that don't use your full
skills that you've been educated for or
you start off as a paid or even an
unpaid intern or you start off in
part-time work in or hotels or
restaurants or other retail areas you're
going to experience about 10 years or
even more of suppressed income and lack
of opportunities for growth does it have
to be this way I don't believe that for
a moment there's no iron law of
economics that produce these results
it's the results of bad policies of our
institutions and the way in which we
govern work failing to catch up with
changing workforce and the changing
nature of work and we can do better and
in fact many firms are doing better some
companies are way ahead in providing
good jobs a lot of innovation is
happening at the local level in startups
in nonprofit organizations in state and
local governments we're going to look at
some of those innovations in our next
video and ask how you can join this
process so that we can improve the work
life of everyone going forward
you